you're gonna lose your mind when that
segment comes
yeah LL Cool J salt and pepper Queen
Latifah just a few of the many artists
celebrating 50 years of hip-hop at the
2023 Grammys I think it's about all
generations I think it's
multi-generational first LL gives a
backstory about the star-studded
performance working closely with one of
the most respected and talented groups
in the world the roots Quest love has
curated something spectacular a flash
forward through a half century of one of
the greatest ongoing musical stories
ever told and it starts with the birth
of hip-hop in 1973 including Run DMC
performing king of rock he was then
joined by LL believe me I Like it Loud
I'm the man with the
I think that this would be a way for
people of all generations to kind of Buy
in Mom Dad kids grandkids the spotlight
was on the ladies too salt and Peppa
Missy Elliott and Queen Latifah
we had a lot of a lot of Representatives
do but it's gonna it's 50 50 a year we
got 365 days of that to celebrate and
more musicians came together to
celebrate the anniversary in a big way
including gorilla Chuck D Flavor Flav
Method Man Jay-Z Busta Rhymes and many
more and it was all curated by the one
and only Quest love so I was just
racking my brain I wanted I wanted to be
all inclusive so my first draft was like
27 minutes with over like 100 artists
and they laughed me out the office like
nah no do something normal like 12
minutes and I was like you know so
tonight is going to be a 14 minute
retrospective of some of the most
beautiful music ever created by the most
beautiful people
you know ever so
[Music]